[Music]
on this Friday night the U.S
commander-in-chief visits Canada's
parliament Americans and Canadians are
two people two countries in my view
sharing one heart the progress on key
issues and the Wise Cracks I like your
teams except the Leafs
plus the salute to two special guests
Israel's prime minister Under Fire
breaking the law why critics say
democracy in Israel is in jeopardy
and avian flu fears soar the calls to
vaccinate humans against this virus
[Music]
professional with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with the American president's
visit to Canada it was Joe Biden's first
visit to Ottawa since he was elected
president a chance for he and prime
minister Justin Trudeau to renew the
relationship between the U.S and Canada
which share long-standing economic
defense and National Security
Partnerships
we're lucky we have Canada to our North
share these values all the values are
the same we disagree and agree on things
occasionally but there's no fundamental
difference in the Democratic Values we
share
Biden addressed Parliament stressing how
interconnected the two countries are
there's news tonight about immigration
on official border crossings at places
like roxham Road in Quebec will be
closed as of midnight tonight as well
defense and Haiti are on the agenda
David Aiken was listening to Biden's
speech and has our top story tonight
[Applause]
good friends Canada and the United
States but friends with issues
nonetheless U.S President Joe Biden
prime minister Justin Trudeau and key
members of their cabinets spent the day
working through those issues and both
sides say they made significant progress
Mr President as it should be our two
Nations Stand United in this moment
finding Solutions side by side on
Canada's concern about irregular
migrants flowing into Quebec at the
roxham road border entry a deal that
ends that practice and returns anyone
who tries to walk into Canada from the
U.S back to the U.S that goes into
effect at midnight tonight Canada
meanwhile has committed to take in 15
000 more regular migrants a year from
Central and Latin America we're
expanding legal Pathways for migration
to seek safety in humanitarian
humanitarian basis while discouraged and
unlawful migration that feeds
exploitation and human trafficking on
Haiti Canada is putting up a hundred
million dollars worth of Aid to boost
police forces there but no commitments
on sending Personnel for now Canadian
government sources though say the bigger
news from this state visit involves
plans to further integrate our economies
economies now in transition to a Greener
future economic policy is climate policy
is security policy there's an agreement
on a new cross-border semiconductor
manufacturing strategy on a new energy
transformation task force and on new
funds to protect the great lakes and the
Arctic today as we stand at as I said
today an inflection point in history our
nations are once again called upon the
lead and together I believe we're
answering the call
now Canada is going to spend hundreds of
millions of dollars to fulfill its
bargain as a part of these agreements
that it announced today look for details
on how and when that money is going to
be spent in next week's federal budget
Donna okay David how is the speech
received
it was received very well and probably
because the president started off by
reminding his audience that the two
countries share so many things including
our shared love of sports
baseball basketball
hockey listen to this hockey
I have to say I like your teams except
the Leafs
now I'm not going to explain why he
doesn't like the Leafs it's a long story
but that got a big laugh that line and
it was a really good Icebreaker for the
speech to start Donna and this was a
speech largely about shared values and
interests David the relationship
certainly does seem less tense than
under the previous president
it does and I think for a lot of
Canadians they were looking for the
president to give what essentially is
the first speech by a U.S president that
is the first post-trump speech and in
that sense Biden was looking to renew
the friendship I think he was looking to
uh smooth some feathers that might have
been ruffled by his predecessor he spoke
for about 45 minutes this was the key
section
today
our Destinies are intertwined
and they're inseparable
not because of the inevitability of
geography
but because it's a choice a choice we've
made again and again
the United States chooses to link our
future with Canada
because we know that we'll find no
better partner
and I mean it's from the bottom of my
heart no more reliable Ally no more
steady friend
and today I say to you and to all the
people of Canada that you will always
always be able to count on the United
States of America
and you can hear the Applause there in
the house at that time everybody was
standing on their feet clapping liberals
conservatives new Democrats all the
guests in the gallery and I think
they're hoping and wishing that that
sentiment remains true Donna okay David
thanks so there were multiple standing
ovations during the speech including for
two of the guests who are in the gallery
Michael spavor and Michael kovrig who
were detained in China for more than one
thousand days
and I'm very glad to see the two
Michaels the two Michaels Michael stravo
and Michael phelpring
they're safely back to their families
the president acknowledged them and
stressed the importance Canada and the
U.S place on defending human rights
Biden didn't talk about China in his
speech but it was part of the agenda
during the meetings and it came up
during a joint press conference this
afternoon our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson was there Mercedes
well Donna obviously a visit that really
struck a lot of positive notes on major
issues everything from trade to Regional
integration to security was discussed
but there was one issue as you just
mentioned that was notably absent until
it was raised by a Canadian reporter
that was the question of China prime
minister Justin Trudeau was asked to
respond to reports about Ontario MP
handong engaging with the Consulate
General in Toronto for Beijing over the
two Michaels the Prime Minister was
asked whether he believed that dong
advocated for the delayed release of
Michael kovrig and Michael spavor the
Prime Minister did not directly answer
that question despite his office having
said that they've seen a transcript of
that conversation he did however take a
moment to speak about Dong take a listen
to what he had to say
Han gave a strong speech in the house
that I recommend people listen to and we
fully accept that he is stepping away
from the liberal caucus in order to
vigorously contest these allegations
and Don important to note that Han dong
has vigorously denied the allegations
and says that he only ever advocated for
the two Michaels to be released
immediately President Biden was also
asked about whether he wanted to respond
on China's alleged interference but he
just kind of shook his head and didn't
answer anything at one point he did
mistakenly refer to Canada as China
though during his address to Parliament
turning that misstep into a joke to tell
MPS that now they know what he's really
thinking about but for whatever reason
he didn't articulate it any further than
that and China was much less on the
agenda publicly than it has been when
the two leaders have previously met
and Mercedes what's your sense of what
this visit has accomplished
well there were some serious victories
for the Trudeau government including the
renegotiation of the safe Third Country
agreement which will kick in tonight at
midnight as you were just discussing
with David it wasn't clear heading into
the meeting whether the Americans would
be willing to close that irregular
Crossing at roxham Road of course people
are Crossing into Canada there but there
needed to be a renegotiation of the safe
Third Country agreement to accomplish
that and it looks like they've got that
kicking in very quickly so it's a
significant win the leaders also talked
about securing access for electric
vehicles to American markets and they
shared their commitment to defense and
security there were also major
announcements about NORAD including a
system to be built here in Canada a
strong message on the importance of
defense and security including NATO and
supplying more troops and training
pardon me more training for troops and
weapons as well for Ukraine defense
spending of course has been something
that both Republican and Democrat
presidents have wanted to see Canada
step up one Mercedes thanks the bidens
are at a Gala dinner hosted by the Prime
Minister a long list of notable
Canadians are expected to be is at the
venue turia do we know who's invited
well Donna The Unofficial guests of
honor are the two Michaels now they just
arrived moments ago they walked along
this red carpet now they didn't take any
of our questions they smiled and waved
but the fact that they're here is quite
remarkable it was an unexpected
invitation
um and both Michaels have kept a
relatively low profile since their
release from a Chinese prison they've
given few interviews so the fact that
they're here you know is quite symbolic
it's a real symbol of Canadian and U.S
Partnerships it was U.S President Joe
Biden who was quite instrumental in
negotiations ahead of their release so
quite remarkable to see them here
and there are other there are about 450
dignitaries and delegates who were here
politicians celebrities so it's quite a
long list but it's really these two men
who everybody's been watching for
Ontario do we know what's on the program
for tonight
well it's already gotten underway it
began with performances there were Inuit
throat singers and made tea jiggers Alan
Doyle is also expected to perform and
then there are going to be speeches
toasts and then the dinner
um and there are others there are other
notable Canadians who are here Sarah
Paulie she just won an Academy Award and
a very famous Canadian comedian Eugene
Levy so we spoke to him a little bit
earlier take a listen
it's very very very special I mean you
know I I uh I'm glad to be here it's an
honor to be here
um
it's nice to know I picked the right
profession
uh probably wouldn't have been here
otherwise conservative leader Pierre
pauliev also attended tonight's Gala it
caps off a two-day visit for the bidens
once dinner wraps up they'll make their
way back to the U.S Donna right Korea
isri in Ottawa tonight thanks the first
lady Jill Biden had a chance to explore
a bit of Ottawa today including
something quintessentially Canadian
Ford Trudeau accompanied the first lady
as they watched young athletes at a
curling practice they also took part in
a discussion about mental Wellness with
some young Canadians and no trip to
Ottawa would be complete without
stopping at the National Gallery Jill
Biden toured an exhibit featuring
Canadian women artists
Israel's attorney general says his prime
minister has broken the law coming up
The Firestorm facing Benjamin Netanyahu
in Israel prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu refuses to back down on
judicial reforms that many believe are
fundamentally undemocratic
anger accelerated on the streets
yesterday after netanyahu's right-wing
coalition government passed a new law
making it harder to remove the Prime
Minister from office and there's anger
that changes Netanyahu is making to the
justice system will give his government
the final say in choosing the country's
judges it has reached the point that
hundreds of soldiers and reservists are
refusing to obey orders and even
Israel's attorney general Lawrence
Netanyahu is breaking the law Eric
Sorensen reports
sister thought a quick trip to London
would afford him a break from his
troubles at home
he was mistaken
protesters outside ten Downing like
those in Israel are furious with an
Israeli law they say will give more
power to Netanyahu
and we are all Israelis to fight
yesterday the Israeli knesset passed the
law
it allows Parliament to override Court
decisions and makes it harder for the
courts to remove a leader Netanyahu has
been charged with bribery and fraud
which he denies his attorney general
wrote an open letter that it was illegal
for him to be involved in making changes
while he is on trial
I will do everything everything he says
to unite the country but adds the law
will restore the proper balance between
the courts and Parliament
many Israelis see a leader simply trying
to protect himself
the prime minister of Israel
Netanyahu has formed a hard-right
coalition government his Finance
Minister said in Paris this week there
is no such thing as Palestinian people
Ottawa condemned the remarks as did
Washington which normally stands with
Israel we utterly
object to that kind of language in the
West Bank Palestinians decried his
remarks
we belong to this land said the
Palestinian prime minister but it is
among Israelis themselves that Netanyahu
faces a crisis even in the military many
Israeli reservists who play a big part
in Israeli Society are refusing to
report when called up their
it is costing Netanyahu at home and
Israel's stature abroad this is
it's an assault on judicial Independence
opposition to this government throughout
the state of Israel and throughout the
world Netanyahu May hope the opposition
loses Steam and goes away but for now it
follows him wherever he goes Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
bird flu fears ahead do we need a human
vaccine for Avian Influenza
cases of avian flu and birds are on the
rise in many countries including Canada
and health experts warn the strain of
viruses is changing in ways that raises
concerns it could potentially drive
another pandemic the risk of
transmission to humans is low at the
moment but as Catherine Ward reports
that could change
the headlines the worldwide avian bird
flu outbreak is causing concerns amongst
researchers and the closures the birds
are under quarantine because of a threat
posed by avian flu the spread of bird
flu in Canada since late 2021 has
experts on alert your first fate was in
March of 2022 second day was
approximately in August or September of
2022 and this is the third set of
outbreaks that we're seeing in in
Ontario while experts have maintained
the risk to the general population is
low the way the virus has been behaving
in recent months is Raising concerns
other animals are getting infected
including skunks and seals here in
Canada and what scientists refer to as
spillover events it seems that the virus
has become adapted or is in the process
of becoming adapted to mammals that is
very disconcerting because that could be
a Prelude to adaptation to humans and
that's precisely what we don't want to
these wires to do cases of avian flu in
people are rare but not unheard of
particularly in Asia and the Middle East
so when these viruses do cause human
infections the mortality rate can be as
high as 50 percent some experts say
production of a human vaccine for bird
flu needs to be on the table sooner
rather than later
there are actually a lot of large
multinational seasonal flu vaccine
manufacturers who are capable of making
bird flu vaccines using their existing
infrastructure experts know the value of
being prepared there will be more
pandemic potential viruses emerging and
we need to have a much better system and
much better mechanism for predicting how
when and where viruses are going to
emerge Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
next who's paying attention to the U.S
president's
visit
the relationship between the U.S and
Canada outlasts whoever happens to be in
power but the personalities and the
politics of the leaders can affect the
relationship right now the Prime
Minister and the president are said to
genuinely like each other and it
certainly appears that way so what's the
reaction to this visit in the nation's
capital Mike Armstrong went to find out
if you shot it from some angles you
could make it look like a lot of people
it really wasn't yeah well we were here
for Prince Charles and Camilla and it
was a lot of people
this was basically one of the best spots
to spot President Joe Biden in downtown
Ottawa along the motorcade Road this man
brought his young son for what was a
rare opportunity it's kind of an
important person you know they say is
the most powerful person in the world
right so
is happening when the moment came it was
of course one of those blink and you
missed it occasions it was about 30
seconds of actual action right like was
it worth it oh sort of there was a lot
of cars a lot more than I thought there
would be I thought he might wave or
something right but you couldn't even
tell where he was yeah I couldn't even
tell
now a presidential visit to Ottawa is a
big deal this reporter has covered a few
Barack Obama in 2009 we did excitement
stories before during and after
when Bush visited in 2004 yes I'm that
old protesters prepared for weeks for
Action I think it's quite a good start
we got a lot of people out here
well for this presidential visit
Ottawa seems to be lacking enthusiasm on
a scale of one to ten how excited are
you about this visit zero now that was
the lowest result we got five six but
overall well admittedly unscientific we
got an average of 3.7 honestly
by the six probably a three how excited
am I uh one
now there was one place excited by the
visit this Ottawa Bakery it was standing
over there Barack Obama dropped by
unexpectedly in his 2009 visit and
bought three Canada cookies the owner
then rebranded them Obama cookies and
for 14 years they've been a huge seller
a million yes Michelle now there was one
moment caught by cameras Wednesday where
Biden was given a Canadian candy bar it
was made by a company started by Syrian
immigrants in Nova Scotia Piece By
Chocolate this visit may be remembered
for what it accomplished rather than
excitement or anything extracurricular
which by the way is pretty typical for
Joe Biden and probably not a bad thing
Mike Armstrong Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the Aurora Borealis you
usually have to travel to the far north
to see Northern Lights like this but
thanks to a geomagnetic storm there
dazzling people in southern Canada even
in the U.S we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching Fara Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see you
again on Monday have a lovely weekend
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]